so one of my favorite fun facts about
crolo is the official english spelling
of his name in the ever-reliable hunt
hunter data book crawler lucifer is
canonically spelled as
quil ralph rusev which was clearly
written by someone who not only has no
comprehension of english but also no
comprehension of japanese because the
name kuroda rushifuru
is not that difficult for either
language hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for everything
anime and manga and today we are here to
zero in on one crollo lucifer of our
beloved phantom troop because i received
a fun
question from a user named leon3624
which is unfortunate because that
implies that there are leon's one
through 3623 but this particular leon
asked me whether or not it would be
possible for crollo to steal a guardian
nen beast which were assigned to the
karkin princes during the succession war
and that's a very interesting query but
it led to an even bigger question
emerging from me
which is are there any net abilities out
there in general that crollo cannot
steal and as it turns out
yes yes there are and more than you
would think there are a mind-boggling
ton of hansu that are just plain immune
to being stolen by skill hunter
for a ton of different fun and technical
reasons and we're going to start this
exploration with a quick round of skill
hunter or skill blunder a very simple
minigame the rules of which are as
follows i am going to present you with
three
none abilities and it is going to be
your job to tell me which of those three
that crollo
is not able to steal should you guess
incorrectly then your punishment will be
to subscribe to the new world review
thus resulting in consistent
injections of hunt hunter culture
administered straight into your youtube
feed and if you are correct then you
will receive this tasty candy so which
of the following abilities is crolo
unable to steal
is it isaac naturo's 100 type guanine
bodhisattva
magical spa services or basho's great
haiku
one of these abilities has an immunity
to crolo so make your choice now and we
shall reveal the answer
in three two one and bam it was the 100
type guanine bodhisattva so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know the
thing to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a fresh member
of the new world association
welcome but why is netro's heart so
immune well to understand that we need a
quick recap of the conditions that skill
hunter needs to meet there are four
criteria to cross
off in order to steal an enability
firstly crowler must witness the ability
with his own eyes
secondly crawler must ask the abilities
owner a question about nen and have them
answer thirdly the owner's power must
touch the cover of the bandit's secret
book and finally
all of this needs to be completed within
the time limit of one
hour and in addition to that even once
an ability is taken crollo then needs to
clear any native conditions that the
hansu may require in order to use it
which is problematic in more than a
couple of cases but let's dwell on our
first criteria for a bit being that
krollo must witness the ability with his
own eyes this is the reason why he would
be unable to steal netero's bodhisattva
because when netero activates it the
ability moves faster than the human eye
can comprehend it even nephipito a
chimera antoil god had no comprehension
of what had happened to them after
falling victim to nettoro's power so
it's more than safe to say that unless
netro wanted to unnecessarily showboat
that crowler would not be able to see
this hatsu in action and therefore
not be able to steal it there's also
several other abilities that fall into
this technicality within the phantom
troop itself actually as pakunota's
psychometry ability would also be immune
this is because the power takes place
entirely in pakinoda's mind you know she
touches someone
reads their memories and that's kind of
that there is no visual evidence of any
sort of ability taking place in fact all
crollow is capable of seeing is pakunoda
touching a little boy
in the back of a car and that that is
not inability
that is a sex crime and we have a very
similar situation in regards to parallel
future the disturbingly powerful hatsu
held by the even more disturbing gir
fourth prince saradnik it allows him to
look 10 seconds into the future and then
alter his own actions to change that
future if you're a jojo fan it's it's
more or less king crimson and if you're
not then
look i'll go into more depth in another
video but once again chrollo is
incapable of seeing this in action in
fact nobody except seradnit can witness
parallel future and as a technicality
because we love those i'd like to bring
up the idea that a very
very skilled end user could also conceal
their abilities with ian and provided
that chrollo isn't using a highly
concentrated go at the time that would
keep your abilities from being seen
i wouldn't count on that though crollo
is is a bit too tricky to fall for
something like that
the whole vision thing is just one skill
hunt criteria though and the next is
also fairly restrictive that crawler
needs to ask a question about nen and be
answered by the owner of the desired
hatsu because there are several cases in
hunt hunter where a potential victim has
no knowledge of nen and is therefore
unable to answer any questions comegy of
course brings to mind her rapidly
evolving gunky ability is very safe from
crollo
in the events that he actually wanted to
take it and become some sort of
invincible gungy master
in that admittedly strange event
komagi's ignorance of nen would save her
in this encounter so there's a profound
life lesson for you
knowledge is every bit as much of a
curse as it is a blessing and the same
could be said for leon's initial
question about the guardian nen beast
held unknowingly i might add by most of
the kakeen princes this may change in
the future but right now the vast
majority of them know little to nothing
about nen
their bodyguards are currently engaged
in a crash course thanks to mr karapica
but the princes themselves largely
remain quite safe very ironically it's
the front runners of the succession war
who would be most susceptible to having
their guardian nb stolen that being
first prince benjamin second prince
camilla and fourth prince radnick all of
whom now have at least a basic
understanding of nen and who knows that
might actually be relevant since the
phantom troop is aboard the blackwell
one and getting involved with these
sorts of
cocking affairs the third condition is
what i would call the most restrictive
though
being that the victim needs to touch the
cover of the bandit's secret book with
their palm
and that palm is pretty specific and
important because there are nen users in
hunter hunter who do not have how shall
we say the equipment required to fulfill
this and that more or less refers to a
selection of chimera ants icalgo for
example only has tentacles
but no palms so crollo cannot steal his
fleedom or living dead dollshatsu and
even if he could he probably wouldn't
want to do it because i can't see crollo
climbing into a corpse in order to
control it meanwhile another example
would be bloster
or brovada look it depends if you read
or watched hunter hunter the viz manga
translation is bluster while the english
subdynamic calls him improvider it
doesn't matter at all because he has
lobster claws and they shoot then
bullets kind of like franklin's ability
actually but very unfortunately or
fortunately i guess it depends who you
are
lobster claws are not palms so that is
yet another ability unable to be stolen
by our head
phantom troop dude guy now for the skill
hunter restriction of needing to do
everything within an hour i couldn't
find anything that would counter this
condition specifically but there are
individuals who would make it
somewhat inconvenient like say chito
because he may be very difficult to
catch within an hour but if anyone could
pull that off it's probably the wits of
crawler
although with that said using crollo's
intelligence against the other the
struggling brain matter of cheeto might
actually result in an unintended
immunity chitu may very well be so
dumb that not even crowler can predict
what horrendous course of action he is
going to take next but what we move on
to now are more vaguely questionable
hatsu abilities that it's difficult to
see crawler performing even if he did
steal them and the first of which is
anything to do with body
transformation many characters hold a
power similar to this such as biski but
we've also seen it used by gone and even
taken to the extreme by chimera and such
a zazon because these are so
individually physically based it's hard
to tell if crawler would be able to use
them although i do love the idea of
stealing biscuits hatsu and krollo
transforming into a super cute
chibi crawler meanwhile other nan
abilities are just a blanket no in this
regard and we need look no further than
the phantom troop with bonolov and his
battle cantabra series in order to
activate any one of the battle
cantabular abilities bernoullinov needs
to play
beautiful music via the halls of his
body so while they will admit that
crawlow can certainly steal these
abilities he would still be unable to
meet the requirements in order to
actually use them because crawler's body
is not the finely tuned holy instrument
of banalino and then there are some just
plain funny ideas like say pike and his
love shower ability once again easily
stolen by crawler but would he be
capable or even
would he want to use it because in case
you've forgotten love shower is
essentially the power
to shoot a web out of your anus
something that is helped by pike's
physicality as a spider and crawler
lacks the
the natural infrastructure to
comfortably pull something like that off
so it does not sound like a pleasant
ability for a human to use but there's
even minor questions that pop
up in regards to stuff like dr blyth
part of that ability is the restriction
that the nen beast is directly connected
to pito via the tail so if crollo were
to take it would crawler grow a tail as
part of that ability or would he simply
not meet the physical requirement to
actually summon dr black there are
questions ever never so many questions
and physical restrictions aren't even
everything because there's also a
plethora of hatsu that are uniquely
difficult to use and i would initially
like to flag melody's enchanting music
as one of these this ability allows
melody to influence the emotion of those
listening to her music
and even alleviate fatigue however this
power works entirely on the basis of
melody's pure passion for music
in combination with her technical skill
as a musician so sure crawler once again
you can steal the ability but if he has
no passion for playing music or a skill
with a particular instrument then it
will have little to no effect although i
can imagine a situation where crollo
takes melody's hatsu then goes and grabs
a random instrument let's say a trumpet
he attempts to play it
accidentally hits a sour note and just
makes everyone listening
sort of [ __ ] themselves that's probably
how it would go down
one that's also infinitely arguable is
karapika's emperor time and this is
because of the vagueties of nen which is
it's the great fun and the great
frustration of hunter hunter i suppose
because it's not clear whether or not
the possession of the scarlet eyes is
required as part of the condition to
activate emperor time and its most basic
interpretation all the scarlet eyes
allow karapika to do is to become a
specialist and then emperor time is a
completely separate power but nen is not
necessarily that straightforward
especially in regards to karapika and
his crazy sets of restrictions and
especially especially in regards to the
kurta eyes which are a bizarrely magical
aberration of the hunter hunter world
very potentially traced back to the dark
continent and i have a whole different
video here exploring that idea which is
very
very well worth watching but as for
emperor time look
it's debatable whereas other abilities
are just plain impractical one of my
favorite niche nin abilities is a very
very recent one in the hunt hunt manga
which is held by almost all of camilla's
gods they come from a very poor and
persecuted section of the kakin empire
and as a result they have developed this
phenomenon of a society-wide non-ability
known as yamatsuhegui which to put into
simple terms it's a curse
a cursor does bad things to its targets
one of those bad things potentially
being death but it is extraordinarily
complicated to pull off
firstly the user must carry an object
connected to their target like a photo
and along with that object they need a
dagger then the user must think of that
target
each and every day until they wish to
activate the curse and to do that they
need to burn the object
drink the ashes and then commit suicide
with the dagger and then depending on
the time taken between starting and
implementing the curse the victim will
suffer a negative effect from having
their order hindered to outright death
however to be effective
at the more death end of the scale this
ability takes years of preparation so
it's very impractical
for krollo to steal and also come to
think of it by the time crolo sees the
power in action i guess the user will
have died due to the whole
suicide thing so it would become
impossible to ask them a question about
nan so they'll come to think that it is
100
immune from crawler all of which is to
say that crollo skill hunter is not the
super op ability that a lot of fans seem
to think it is
because even disregarding how difficult
the conditions are to meet in the very
best of cases
every now ability in every end user is
entirely unique
and as a result of that many of those
users and hatsu will fall outside of the
criteria for skill hunter but to fall
into the criteria of fun here is another
glorious hunter hunter video for you to
watch there is always more to learn
discover and experience about this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there